sheriff's in Los Angeles confirm a
second shooting at a state park where a
man was killed while camping with his
two young daughters
Tristan Beaudette was shot inside his
tent at Malibu Creek State Park his
daughters were unharmed the victim's
brother tells our la station que cbs-tv
there were two holes in Baudette stent
one in the top and one on the side
police have not confirmed if the holes
were bullet holes Carter Evans is at the
sheriff station in Calabasas near the
State Park Carter good morning good
morning it was sheriff's deputies from
this station that first responded to the
shooting on Friday that campground is
closed now after two shootings in the
last five days authorities still don't
know why tristan Beaudette was killed or
who may be responsible this is the area
where Tristan Bogut was shot about 4:45
Friday morning sleeping in a tent with
his two daughters ages 2 and 4 they
found that the victim sustained a
gunshot wound to his upper torso he was
pronounced dead at the scene
Malibu Creek State Park covers some
8,000 acres in the Santa Monica
Mountains about 30 miles west of Los
Angeles
authorities say the parks 63 campsites
were nearly full
investigators were seen focusing on two
campsites in particular 49 and 51 near
the north end of the camping area and
now sheriff's confirmed there was
another shooting in this area around the
same time yesterday morning when a man's
car was hit with a bullet and last year
Melissa tangelo had a similar experience
she posted this video to Facebook in
January of 2017
showing where her Honda was shot while
she was at the park
my boyfriend walked around he was like
that's a bullet hole and I was like okay
it is right so far investigators are not
linking any of the incidents so they are
where there were other shootings however
this is businessing to be related I
think so the pride that he felt the big
smile or the joy he he loved them so
much Rabbi Arnold brockless remembers
Beaudette as a man devoted to his wife
and two young daughters whether it was
intentional or random
still a horrible tragedy and represents
the loss of a husband the loss of the
father
Bouck debt was married to his high
school sweetheart in a statement the
family says their grief is indescribable
John thanks Carter what any mystery so
bizarre and it makes me think that they
certainly know more than they're telling
us right whether Tory yeah the fact that
they're saying they don't think that the
the shootings are related says to me
with my criminal degree that I don't
have yeah they must know something more
to this story it's very very sick
perhaps he was targeted yeah yeah I
think that we'll have an answer on this
case very soon